Tổng thân phần tế của The Guardian Guan, tổng thống Mí Đu Ninh Tram đang áp dụng triển thuật
mềm nắng sáng buông trong sự lý xung độ gối văn. Thế hiện qua việc lân phía
phía nze cấp tuyên bố kinh sẵn và đổng thái sạm leo thang. Sau khi kỉnh báo hản
nắng tấn công tương sẵn nắng lộ gối văn, tổng thống Tram bất ngờ thông báo hóa
hình đạo và nhấn mạnh triển vọc là phán. Xí bế này đã tất cả những người thị trường
tài chính thần cầu khi giả dầu và chính khoa mến động mạnh dừa phục hồi trường hắn hạp.
Tuy nhiên, tương tương của tế trường sẵn, khi nhạc đủ tư trên đến thận trọng trung những thay đổi
liên tục tổng Washington. Châu khi đó, phía y văn bắt bỏ cơ tuyên bố vệ tính trình
nắng phán và tư tuy có hản đậm của sự chẳng khu bật.
Theo dưới quà sát, điều này trước thay mức độ kiểm soát thì hình của Mỹ có thể đang suy zạm.
Bố cảnh hiện nay đã giá thích thích châu Washington trong việc người dưới chiến xe cách,
vừa chẳng料 tháng buồn đồng, có chuyên gia nhận định chính thận Mỹ Nắng Sán Bôn,
có thể khoa suy chỉ được hiệu quả trong một trường liện chính trị ngày càng phức tài.